session chair so i'll introduce myself
hi i'm sam
um thank you all for coming this morning
uh
i'm going to talk about lower bounds
against um some of squares based
algorithms
let me turn down my mic a little so
there's a little feedback thank you
uh great i'm going to talk about lower
balance against some of squarespace
algorithms and this talk so my
um instructions from the organizers
thank you to the organizers very much
for having me by the way my instructions
for the organizers were to give a
tutorial and
okay i have to be there's a lot there's
a lot of material here this is a big
area so i have to be a little bit choosy
about what i can give a tutorial on and
i decided to make it pretty basic
because i think there's um
there's sort of a wide audience here
especially trying to be welcoming to
folks from the crypto side of this of
this workshop so for uh folks who are
sos experts i hope you'll bear with me
for at least the first half of this talk
and maybe you can contribute some
corrections or modifications or
additional citations
if i'm not citing your work it's
not
intentional i promise and i would
appreciate if people tell me what i'm
not up to date on
okay so
um
yeah here's the rough agenda we're going
to talk about what is this sos thing
that you might have heard about the sum
of squares method or sum of squares
algorithm and then try to situate it in
the themes of the workshop so which are
you know learning and high dimensional
statistics and complexity thereof and
average case complexity and service of
cryptography
and then um having motivated things
which will actually use a significant
amount of the talk because i want to
give you a sense for what these sos
algorithms are and what they can do
then we'll move to lower bounds uh and
okay i'll talk sort of briefly about
what we know what i think is kind of the
state of the art this is an active very
active area so uh for instance
10 minutes ago i just heard about a new
result that i had sort of heard a little
bit about but you know okay i won't
quite make it into the talk
um and then you know where we hope to be
in in some years
and we'll conclude with some open
problems
okay
so what is sos
let's think about it purely kind of
abstractly without putting it in
learning or crypto contexts for starters
at heart
sum of squares or sos is an algorithm
for the following kind of decision
problem
it's an algorithm that takes in
a system of polynomial inequalities with
uh real coefficients and thinking of it
as having real valued variables
and asks does this system of polynomial
inequalities have a solution right so do
p1 through pm is there some point in rn
such that p1 through pm are all
simultaneously non-negative at that
point
um
of course this is an np-hard problem
right so
uh if somebody comes along and tells you
that they have an algorithm that solves
this problem you should ask well when
does it work and that will kind of be
the name of the game and understanding
sos is to understand for what kind of
polynomial systems does sos do a good
job of deciding this we'll say a little
bit more in a moment about what it can
really do
um
but before before getting any deeper you
know why would you be interested in this
problem in the first place what makes it
special among the range of np-hard
problems you might try to come up with
some kind of methods to to address
well polynomials are just an extremely
expressive mathematical language and
that you know shouldn't be surprising to
people in either statistics or
cryptography
you know because polynomials can talk
about so many different things it means
that if you have that the sum of squares
algorithm can be used to address
algorithmic problems in an incredibly
wide range of of areas so it's been a
tremendous success in combinatorial
optimization because polynomials can
talk about
graphs and tours and sets and all that
kind of stuff it actually has its
origins and robotics and optimal control
um
where it's used to design and understand
leopardous functions so potential
functions that can govern the behavior
of a dynamical system uh
it's very useful in quantum information
it's turned out to have applications
actually a huge number of applications
in algorithm design for high dimensional
statistics and average case algorithms
and it's turned out to actually have
applications in building attacks against
candidate cryptosystems so these two
things i will discuss more later in the
talk of course this is only a subset of
the kinds of things that sos can do but
this is just to convince you you know
why should you care about polynomials
because polynomials can talk about just
about anything
okay so back to sos
um in the next few slides i'm going to
try to give you a picture
uh at a you know at a more concrete
level um
of what you know what is sos doing when
it tries to decide whether or not p1
through pm uh can be simultaneously
non-negative over rn
the key concept that we need is called a
sum of squares proof
okay so
let's think about for a second
if i gave you this polynomial system
and
uh i also gave you some kind of a proof
let's think first about a proof that
this system can be simultaneously solved
well that kind of proof could be very
simple i could just give you the point x
that does it
right so there's short witnesses of
solvability
but what about short witnesses of
unsatisfiability
do those exist what what could they even
look like a sum of squares proof
is
one kind of way that a short or a small
witness of unsatisfiability of a system
could look
it's the following thing
it consists of a bunch of other
polynomials i'm going to call them q
q's one q for every subset of the
equations
okay and all of these polynomials they
should be sums of squares of other
polynomials
okay
um
that means in particular because
everything we're doing is over the reals
that all of these polynomials are
everywhere non-negative
because squares are non-negative over
reals
the property that this set of
polynomials should have
is the following
identity of polynomials so the
coefficients of this polynomial in x
should be all equal to the coefficients
of this polynomial in x that's the
constant polynomial called minus 1.
the identity is that if i sum up over
all the subsets
and i multiply the sos polynomial
corresponding to that subset to the
product of the
constraint polynomials is what i'll
start calling these in that subset
that that sum is negative 1.
um so why should this convince you if i
show you these guys
why should it convince you that this
system is not satisfiable
well suppose it were suppose there was
an x that satisfied it then you know
these products would all be non-negative
at that x
these guys are everywhere non-negative
so i would have a non-negative number
equal to -1 and that's impossible
furthermore if i show you the cues
then you know by just computing out
these products and looking at the
coefficients you can check whether this
polynomial identity holds
so this is what a short
a small witness of unsatisfiability
could look like in what sense would it
be small
well we're going to have a measure of
the complexity of this witness it's
called the degree and it's just the
maximum degree of any term in this sum
so we'll say a proof is degree d if
every term in this sum is degree d is a
polynomial in x
so sos has a huge history actually it
goes all the way back to hilbert's 17th
problem
um but there's kind of two highlights in
this history that i want to mention
because they're relevant to us
the first
is a totally remarkable fact that comes
out of 70 years of algebraic geometry or
something like that
um
you know i told you this very specific
form of a witness of unsatisfiability
and you might ask well how specific was
that like if i just give you a some
polynomial system that's not satisfiable
should i expect for it to have one of
these witnesses and the remarkable
answer is yes
every unsatisfiable system of polynomial
inequalities has a sum of squares proof
of unsatisfiability
so this is a deep result in algebraic
geometry
um
from the computer science perspective
though
we want to understand the complexity of
these sum of squares proofs because it
turns out the complexity of sos proofs
will correspond to running time of
algorithms that we um that we get out of
them
and for this the important foundational
result is by pirillo and laser who
showed that using semi-definite
programming you can decide the existence
of a degree d proof
in time which is polynomial in the size
of this system and exponential in d
okay
think of them as being over the reels in
many variables but of course any any
constrained set that i can describe as a
low degree variety
i can build with this right so i can
build the hypercube for instance
by you know the plus minus one hypercube
for instance for adding among these
polynomials the constraints x i squared
equals one
okay so this is the foundational
algorithmic results in sum of squares
and i won't talk about how you use
semi-definite programming to do this
we'll work at the at this abstract level
of polynomials yeah so is the original
result that's a brexit contain any bound
on the degree of the sum of square true
uh
i think okay i don't i don't i don't
know enough to tell you exactly what
this result says i think not
um there are results that give you
bounds on degrees under relatively mild
assumptions
like for instance you can say well mild
from a computer science perspective for
instance if i if i say that the
hypercube is among these constraints
like
i have for every variable i at xi
squared equals one
um then the degree is at most n where n
is the number of variables i can prove
anything true in in degree n and there
are similar results for the sphere like
if i have if i have a norm of x squared
is one then you know you can't prove
exactly you can get like additive
approximations to the to the truth
somehow
um
so in the kind of settings that we use
in computer science the right way to
think of it is that once you get up to
degree which is linear in the number of
variables you can probably prove
everything you want
look for sphere though i don't think we
know a linear degree
we only know cubic bound i think
what about this um
dougherty
i thought they proved they don't roam
linear ah okay that's what it was yeah i
see okay well we should okay we should
investigate uh offline the high level
picture is that in in when you make some
assumptions you can get some
quantitative degree bounds
under no assumptions you know there just
shouldn't be degree bounds like uh
it should be arbitrarily bad
okay so all this means that what we get
is some kind of very nice proving power
versus running time trade-off right if i
want to know something about a
polynomial system the the harder the
system is i might need to spend more
time but there is always some amount of
time that i can spend in order to learn
whether the system is satisfiable or not
um
but for computer science
what we really care about is what
happens at
uh you know what we can do in polynomial
time or maybe
between polynomial and exponential or
something like that so what can we do
with low degree sum of squares proofs
that correspond to polynomial time
algorithms
what's really remarkable is that
this one algorithm checking whether or
not a polynomial system is satisfiable
seems to capture
as special cases um the best available
algorithms for an incredibly wide range
of problems worst case problems average
case problems the whole the whole gamut
so i'm going to illustrate this
throughout the talk with several
examples to give you a sense of the
breadth of power of this algorithm
um and here's here's a fun example from
worst-case uh you know classic
algorithms you learned in you know
undergrad algorithms class what about
the min cut algorithm min cut max flow
right we know that you can find the min
cut of a graph in polynomial time well
sos captures this it turns out and you
can actually prove this using the min
cut max flow theorem
that if the minimum cut of a graph has
size uh
c then there will be a constant degree
sum of squares proof that no cut in that
graph has
a value less than c okay i didn't tell
you how to just how to encode cuts as
polynomials and stuff you know that's
like but then you know you can encode
stuff as polynomial familiar with that
so sos captures you know ford full
percent
something kind of more amazing
is that if i change the problem from min
cut to max cut we all know that
the complexity goes crazy right like it
becomes a very different looking problem
it's suddenly np hard we have
approximation algorithms not exact
algorithms and yet
even though the problem computationally
looks very different we actually know
that the best available algorithms are
also captured by sos
so if the max cut of a graph has value c
we actually know that there's a degree
to sos proof
not that no cut has value bigger than c
because then max cut would be solved by
polynomial time sos
but that no cut has has size more than c
over this funny universal constant 0.878
which you might recognize from the
gomes-williamson algorithm from maxcut
so sos is capturing the gomez-williamson
algorithm for maxcut
and in fact
this this uh
this quantitative relationship is the
best you can possibly hope for under the
unique games conjecture and that picture
that for this constraint satisfaction
problem sos captures the best available
algorithm subject to unique games is not
only true for mascot it generalizes to
every constraint satisfaction problem
okay so i hope i've convinced you that
at least
from some worst case uh algorithmic
settings sos is capturing an incredible
range of uh of algorithms right we yeah
this constant the 0.878 approximation
factor yeah
um i mean okay for different csps you'll
have different numbers
but
right
okay so i want to move on to average
case algorithms and learning and
statistics
and
the high level picture on the
algorithmic side is that
you know again sos captures um the best
algorithms we know for a tremendously
wide range of very basic uh average case
problems right so by average case
problems here i mean
um problems where there's a particular
distribution that that god gives you on
some graphs or tensors or matrices or
something and you have to do some
computational problem given graphs or
tensors or matrices from that
distribution so this is a bit different
from like the more classical average
case complexity world distant p where
the distribution is a little bit more
negotiable
so for instance problems that many of us
know and love planted clique refutation
of random constraint satisfaction
problems uh
planted independent sets in sparse
graphs and and more sum of squares
captures the best known algorithmic
guarantees and i'm gonna say i'm going
to you know if you don't not familiar
with these problems we're going to go in
detail on one of them um plan to fleek
in a moment
um but as as a as an aside
you know these are all kind of classical
average case problems that we've studied
to death but
um
and for many of them okay the best known
algorithms are captured by sum of
squares but you don't necessarily need
some of squares to design those
algorithms one of the tremendous
successes of sos in recent years has
been that it's been a really good lens
to translate a lot of insights from this
kind of classical average case world and
bring them into high dimensional
statistics
a huge a huge range of machine learning
high dimensional statistics problems so
we've seen an explosion of algorithms
for robust statistics latent variable
models tensor problems factor analysis
all kinds of
things that are more familiar to
statisticians
and they use a lot of new insights but
they also draw upon insights that were
gained from these um
kind of classical settings
okay but this talk is not really about
that although that's what a lot of this
semester
is related to
okay um still on this on this theme of
the power of sum of squares before we
talk about lower bounds i want to give
an example of planted clique uh to give
you a sense for what what does the sum
of squares algorithm really look like in
these average case settings
so let's refresh ourselves about planted
clique which is one of these basic
average case problems it's easy in some
cases it's computationally hard and
others and you know one of the big goals
is to understand
when and why does it switch from easy to
hard
um so in planet click the goal is to
distinguish between these two
distributions on random graphs the first
is i'll give you a graph from the erdish
rendering distribution gn half
and the second is i'll give you a sample
from erish rainy but i've hidden a cake
leak
right so for on some number of vertices
k and as long as k is much bigger than
two times log n this k cleak will be the
unique cake leak in the graph so of
course if i just did brute force search
over calculates i would be able to find
it
um
just to remind ourselves polynomial time
algorithms are known for this problem as
long as k is bigger than square root of
n
and conjecturally
if k is much less than root n the
problem becomes computationally
intractable
and
um if k is less than you know this this
conjecture has a huge number of
consequences uh i actually failed to
list the consequences for um you know
the learning side but there are a huge
number of reductions uh many of them due
to guy and his collaborators um that
start with planted clique and get to
hardness of a tremendous range of
um of learning problems but just to
point out that there are consequences
even outside of statistics you can
construct private key cryptography under
under this assumption
or maybe maybe small variant of it but
so
you know the fact that this has so many
consequences means it's important to
understand
you know what are the best algorithms
here and do we really believe that they
have to break down
when you go below square root of n
yeah
what's the goal do you want to
distinguish with constant probability or
what kind of probability
good question let's okay i mean
it's
i think i think uh okay the way that i
think about it is constant probability
but you raise a good point that in
crypto applications we often think of
much higher probability distinguishing
as being what we want to want to rule
out and actually
you know
you can distinguish between these
distributions with advantage like one
over polynomial in n
right so i can
i can do a little bit better than random
guessing um if i just write if i just
flip a coin if i don't even look at the
graph to try to distinguish i'll
distinguish with probability one half
right but if i look at something very
trivial like the number of edges in the
graph you know this graph has a few more
edges and that gives me a little bit of
advantage over random guessing and
distinguishing these two
so
yeah there's absolutely a subtle point
here about probability of distinguishing
i'm going to think about distinguishing
with with it with constant advantage as
being the kind of problem i'm interested
in
just for this talk
okay so so every talk should have a a
proof and um this talk was a tutorial so
i thought that i would walk us through
kind of carefully you know how do you
get from like people say all the time
while sos captures this this algorithm
or that algorithm i thought it would be
worthwhile to spend five minutes really
seeing how that how that goes so um
i hope you'll forgive me for doing a
proof but i was gonna show i'm going to
show that um sos captures this uh square
root of n size clique algorithm for
planted clique
so what do i
first of all what do i even do to use
this system this this algorithm for
refuting polynomial inequalities how do
i use it to
just to just solve this distinguishing
distributions problem
well i've got to decide
to translate this distinguishing
distributions problem into a problem
about refuting a polynomial system
and this is actually a little bit subtle
we're going to return to this point
later just what polynomial system should
i choose because it could have
consequences
but
in this setting there there's kind of a
canonical choice that people have
studied for a long time
and what it is is we'll encode um
being a clique of size k in this given
graph as a system of polynomial uh
equations you know i can simulate
equations with inequalities by putting
greater than and less than right so
let's just work with equations
um
and then what i'm going to do i'm going
to have this system of equations notice
that cis that these equations define
we could clear code of size k we'll go
through why they do that in a moment and
then i'll try to refute that system
right and if sos can refute that system
it means that there's no clique of size
k in this graph because this system was
unsatisfiable and any satisfying
solution to this system would have been
a clique
so why is this defined clicks
well i have n variables one for every
node in the graph
this constraint says those variables
have to take 0 1 values so they're an
indicator vector for a subset of
vertices
these variables say that for every edge
in the graph um
that's right for every non-edge in the
graph uh
either you know the left endpoint or the
right endpoint takes the value zero so
you can't have a non-edge in your fleet
and this says that there are k vertices
in the clique
okay so the algorithm will be take the
graph write down these equations
feed it to the sos algorithm and ask for
a proof of unsatisfiability
okay so this is the only only slide with
math in this talk but i thought i would
show you you know how does it really how
does it really go and if you want to let
your eyes blaze over for a couple
minutes you know i won't be offended uh
so what i'm gonna show so it's a fact
that um
a degree d
proof
of unsatisfiability exists when the
clique size is like square root of n
over two to the d and this is this gives
you the best running time versus fleet
size trade-off that we know of
and this is all with high probability
over a randomly chosen graph from gn
half
so
you know
how does this really go
well what we have to do is construct
that proof right
which means that i need to be able to
write minus one
as
some
uh
sum of polynomials that are supposed to
be non-negative if i had a clique
so let me just sort of show how this how
this would go
and it's a little bit of symbolic
manipulation but the goal is to
basically pull out uh pull out
polynomials from
take some simple starting points and
rewrite and rewrite and rewrite until we
get a bunch of polynomials that are
supposed to be zero according to our
constraints
okay so what would i do
here's a first fact
if i start with
k squared which is the size of the peak
eventually i want an upper bound on this
quantity i'm going to rewrite it in some
in some funny way
start with k squared well according to
this constraint that's going to be equal
to
uh the sum of the x i's squared which if
i expand this polynomial is equal to the
sum over all pairs x i x j
and now i'm going to split up the sum
over all pairs x i x j
into the edges
and the non-edges
and now because of
this constraint
i'm allowed to freely add and subtract
edges and non-edges
okay so that this allows me to just
freely add and subtract edges and
non-edges
and that means that eventually i can
write k squared as
uh
the quadratic form
of x at the at a centered adjacency
matrix for this graph
plus some stuff which is supposed to be
zero according to my
constraints there should be a factor two
for the pink stuff right yeah probably
i'm missing a factor of two
thanks
good catch
uh you're saying center to j because uh
the center of this matrix should have
like halves like plus half minus half
when you actually subtract it so you had
all pairs
and i think oh yes yes yes i have a two
here
yeah good points okay so i'm missing it
too thank you pravesh
um
so now i can do some some additional
rewriting on this centered adjacency
matrix i'm going to use i'm going to use
the fact that um
the
a random plus minus 1 matrix has maximum
eigenvalue that scales like root n and
i'm probably missing another constant
here um to use an eigenvalue like a like
a spectral decomposition of
root n times the identity matrix
minus this adjacency matrix that'll be a
psd matrix quadratic forms of psd
matrices are sums of squares so i can do
another rewrite step where i take this
quadratic form and i write it in this
sum of squares form so i picked up a sum
of squares polynomial and i picked up
the norm of of x
um this doesn't quite look right but i
think it's just because i'm presenting
live
anyway
let me not go through in too much detail
i think i i think i i'm overloaded on
the detail on this slide but the point
is by doing more of these constraint
rewrites
we can arrive at a situation where if i
add up
1 and 2
i'll end up with something that looks
like this
this is what we should focus on for now
i'm going to get
some some number that i can control by
by messing around with k
is equal to some sum of squares that i
got out of the spectral decomposition of
the adjacency matrix plus pink stuff
and pink stuff is all supposed to be
zero
right
now the last thing to check is that i
can make this number be minus one and i
will have succeeded in writing minus one
as equal to is in this special sos proof
form why is this the special sos proof
form well you know what i had to do was
sum up uh
my constraints times some polynomials
and look these are all pink stuff was
all constraints
so
all we have to do is check that we can
get minus 1 here but this is root n
times k minus k squared so if k is
bigger than root n i can make this side
negative
okay thank you all for your patience
um
so this is this is you know this is how
sos is able to capture this famous
spectral algorithm for planted leak
okay i have one more algorithmic example
and then i'm going to finally turn to
lower bounds and this is not going to be
in any detail but since we talked about
average case
average case algorithms
and the workshop is about connections to
cryptography let me mention that
uh sos has had applications
algorithmically as a way to stress test
cryptosystems a way to stress test new
assumptions in cryptography
so there's this recent um breakthrough
construction of uh indistinguishability
obfuscation which is this extremely
important um but elusive uh power
primitive for cryptography
um before this construction though there
were many candidate constructions years
and years of candidate constructions and
the more recent generations of those
constructions as the constructions got
simpler and simpler so that they were
amenable to some rigorous analysis
they basically showed that some kind of
new structured pseudorandom generator
implies the existence of
indistinguishability obfuscation so you
need not just any old prg but a prg with
some special structure and then many of
these papers they sort of they would
assume
that a prg like this exists so they
would suggest some candidates for for
things which might be prgs with this
with this special structure
but it turned out that these structured
prgs or the candidates at least that
were suggested were repeatedly broken by
application of somo square's algorithms
right
and
you know this is not a knock against
these constructions because actually the
insights gained from breaking the the
constructions i think eventually led to
the construction which works
um but it shows that you need to you
know you need to worry about sos attacks
if you're going to start making
assumptions uh in crypto
okay
so
why should we do sos lower bonds now i'm
done talking about algorithms
um what is what is the merit of proving
impossibility results for sos based
algorithms
well i would kind of say there are two
views
one is kind of a conservative view it
just says well sos is a powerful
algorithm i'd like to know
when it does and doesn't work so i can
know when to use it when do you try to
use something else you know when to give
up
uh
and you know there's a long history in
crypto of trying to rule out attacks
uh against your crypto system from some
restricted family of algorithms maybe
you say sos is another good family of
algorithms to try to rule out attacks
from
there's a more there's a grander view as
well and i'm not going to commit to
either of you and you don't have to
commit either if you want to prove lower
bonds because you can just do the math
but there's a grander view
that says maybe we can try to use sos as
a broad lens on average case hardness
right for a lot of these average case
problems we're missing anything like np
hardness we're starting to have a
reductions based picture but even that
picture needs to start with an
assumption of hardness of something like
planted clique and for that where's your
evidence
um because we don't have you know two
way or a web of reductions yet
so maybe we can maybe we can say well
sos is so powerful it captures so many
polynomial time algorithms that if i can
rule out sos based algorithms for some
problem it's really good evidence that
there's no algorithm for that problem in
polynomial time so i would call this the
sort of sos optimal view
and i think it's
a very nice way to think about some
kinds of problems but there are it's
subtle what kind of problems this view
could apply to and i'm going to try to
elucidate that a little bit farther in
the talk
okay so here's here's where we're at i'm
gonna move to um
what what do we know what kind of sos
lower bonds do we know about
uh
and very very broadly vaguely what are
the techniques used to prove them and
then discuss you know what kind of lower
bounds can we hope for going forward and
then end with some open questions i'm
i'm running a little bit fast actually
so if people want to discuss points
you know that would be delightful
okay
so i can't survey all of known sos lower
bounds there's too many uh this is this
is something that's been studied now for
more than 20 years
but um
i'll focus on these kind of classical
average case problems these two are
especially classical um refuting random
constraint satisfaction and planted
gleek and then some more some more
modern ones and i'm actually not going
to give too much detail on on any of
these i'm going to try to zoom out and
say like what
what kind of statements are meant by
saying you have an sos lower bound for
such a problem and roughly how how do
you hope to prove such things
so let's let's return to planted clique
as our example just so that we know
you know
people say all the time oh there's an
sos lower bond for planted clique well
what does it mean what's the theorem
statement really tell you
so remember that our algorithm for
planted clique was take your graph
write down a certain polynomial system
from that graph
check if sos can refute that system
and we what we want to do now is prove a
theorem that says that if uh
if the clique size is much less than
root n then that algorithm doesn't work
so what we have to do is say
well
if i set the clique size to be much less
than root n
then there does not exist an sos
refutation of the quick equations for
that graph
and that's exactly what this theorem
what this theorem says
we got almost all the way there
with a slightly weaker conclusion in the
sense of
you know exactly what kind of sos proof
we allowed sos proofs you could make a
few different definitions we got almost
all the way there in this paper in 2016
and uh schwa peng gave a technical
improvement that gets you really to this
to this statement so i'm happy to
clarify exactly the difference in the
statements offline
um
but i think it's nice to finally be able
to say this thing about about proofs
instead of something a little bit subtly
different so what we can now show is
indeed that statement with high
probability over a sample from g in half
if you take the sos degree to be less
than log n so log n corresponds to
quasi-polynomial running times
um then there is no sos refutation of
this system of equations
okay so that very strongly says that the
algorithm i described doesn't work
when um
when k is less than uh less than root n
so what are some features of this
theorem that extend
to
many or maybe even all of the other
lower bounds we know for some of squares
because i don't want to go stating a
million theorems like this let's just
say what are the theorems what are the
features that generalize
um
they go beyond polynomial time
so actually this is one of the weaker
kind of theorems and it's because
planted flake you can't hope for lower
bonds that go beyond quasi-polynomial
time but for instance in refuting random
constraint satisfaction we know very
strong lower bounds we know lower bonds
that go all the way up to exponential
time
which corresponds to linear sos degree
uh
they also they they basically always
are lower bounds about a particular set
of polynomial equations that you
induce from your
let's say distribution distinguishing
problem
so
if we think about say constraint
satisfaction
there are a couple of problems available
to you if i give you a bunch of
random clauses either i could ask you to
refute the existence of a solution to a
whole bunch of randomly generated
clauses
or i could ask you to distinguish
between two distributions on sets of
clauses one where they're totally random
and there's no solution and one where
i've planted a solution these are subtly
different problems the difference is the
same as this difference between
distinguishing between gn half and g and
half plus a k clique versus a given gn
half prove to yourself that there is no
cake leak
um
most natively
you know the the the easiest
interpretation of this theorem
is that it's about hardness of this
latter refutation problem right it says
sos won't work for refuting
we often interpret it to mean hardness
of the accompanying distinguishing
problem that you can't use sos to
distinguish these two distributions
and to be clear i believe you can't use
sos to distinguish these distributions i
think they're hard but i want to point
out the subtle difference that it's not
quite about that
um
and we'll return to that in just a sec
but i wanted to give you a sense of how
you know how do you prove something like
this
and this will be very you know
very ten thousand foot view
but how could you hope to rule out the
existence of sos proofs
well what we do is uh is use duality
okay so
i didn't tell you this but sos proofs
form some kind of a some kind of a
convex set and to rule out the existence
of an sos proof you need to construct a
dual object to them
and the dual objects take the following
form they're called pseudo expectations
and by the way
when you actually do algorithm design
with sos very often you reason in in the
pseudo expectation point of view rather
than in the sos proof point of view but
for this talk it was easier to talk
about about
proofs so suppose that i wanted
to show that there's no solution that
there's no there's no proof
like this for some system of equations
pjs
well
here's what i could do and in fact it
turns out to be net also necessary to do
this
i could construct a linear operator
which traditionally we write e tilde
that takes
degree d polynomials and maps them to
real numbers
and it has the following properties one
is it should be normalized the
e tilde applied to the constant
polynomial should be one
and the other is it should be
non-negative on squares so this is a
positive semi-definiteness property of
this linear operator
um
and in order to rule out the existence
of an sos refutation of these equations
it should have the following additional
properties
it should
map any polynomial times
x i squared minus x i which is you know
this side minus this side
to zero
it should map any polynomial times
uh this side minus this side
to zero sorry i have mismatched notation
k versus that but but don't worry k is
supposed to be a little less than root n
and it should map any polynomial times x
i x j for non-edges i j to zero
if i could construct something like this
for a fixed graph g
what i would do is i would apply this
linear operator to both sides of this
supposed sos proof
and i would get on the left
a negative number because it's linear
and e to the one is one
and on the right i would get a
non-negative number
because these guys would all be zero
except for the empty set s
and then the empty set this guy would be
a sum of squares so i'll get something
non-negative
so if this etilda thingy exists it means
that no sos proof can exist and all
basically all constructions all proofs
of sos lower bounds they construct these
objects
now what makes this hard
well
[Music]
no it's not easy uh it would be easy if
i had
if i had illustrated for you a bunch of
convexity facts so
this it's true by convex duality
um it's actually only true under under
some mild assumptions on the pjs that
make the make there basically be no
duality gap
um in some underlying convex program so
if you went out and wrote these up these
things out as convex sets and then you
applied a bunch of like theorems of the
alternatives that you know farkas lemma
and this kind of stuff
you would get this this is a theorem of
the alternative
right either either one of these things
exists or the other one does
but yeah i know it's not it's not
obvious from the way that i've presented
it
okay
so what what makes this hard what makes
this hard for these average case
problems
well
i want to show not a result about some
fixed let's say graph or csp that i can
really get my hands on i want to show
something happens with high probability
for a random graph or a random csp right
i want to show that for this random set
of polynomial equations that i induced
from a graph for a csp
um that there's no sos refutation of
those random equations
and for that i need some kind of rule
like for every g basically or with for
most gs i need to construct one of these
etodas
so i can't really do the construction by
hand right the construction has to be
somehow symbolic in g right there has to
be a rule that tells me how to take this
graph or csp or whatever and map it to a
linear operator e tilde
and the difficulty is like what the heck
should the rule be like how how should
how should this linear operator depend
on g and for a lot of years
this was done in like a very ad hoc
fashion it was just not clear how you
would do this and it was a major
roadblock for constructing uh sum of
squares lower bounds beyond very low
degrees
one place where this was solved early
was for constraint satisfaction
where it turns out that you can do a
sort of inductive construction of uh of
etilda but for other for problems beyond
constraint satisfaction this was a major
sticking point
until
in in 2016
uh
we discovered this technique called
pseudo calibration and it's
not going to work in in the next 15
minutes for me to describe on any
technical level what pseudo calibration
is
but
what it does
is it takes it's a canonical way
to construct this map
that takes as input a supposedly hard
distinguishing problem
so we've got this interesting interplay
between distinguishing and refutation
we're trying to prove a lower bond for a
refutation problem
we need to build this we need this
technical step
and the way we're going to do it is
we're going to switch to distinguishing
and if i can get a hard distinguishing
problem i can get a canonical
construction of this of this e tilde of
the pseudo expectation
so in planted clique you know we're
thinking about this gleek refuting
problem that lives entirely
in gm half
but
to construct this uh this map
we think about the distinguishing
problem g in half versus g and half plus
a cake leak
and we use the fact
that low degree polynomials in the edges
of the graph can't distinguish these two
distributions and it turns out that the
fact that those low degree polynomials
can't distinguish means that you can use
the low degree moments of this
distribution
to construct a rule that maps graphs to
linear operators okay how do you do that
i'm not going to have time to say
um
with this pseudo calibration technique
okay this is
going to be a controversial slide but
i'm willing to to stand up here and
claim that for average case sos lower
bounds it it is or should be
all-powerful like every lower bound that
we know
either
is proved using pseudo-calibration or
maybe a small variant of it and i'm not
committing to exactly how you implement
this rule so you know i'm covering my my
ass here
um
or should or or should be provable this
way so i think we actually maybe don't
know directly i'm not sure anybody wrote
down that the csp proofs were actually
pseudo-calibrated if if anybody has its
prevesh
but
uh but you don't really need them but
they are yeah so so sometimes you can
you can do it in more in other ways
either ad hoc ways or in csps they're
actually very nice ways to do it by
reasoning about graph expansion but
all of these lower bonds can be proved
via pseudo calibration so it it seems to
be a kind of universal technique for
proving sos lower bounds
except
that
the way you analyze it
so far this is kind of a we're getting
to the state of the union part of this
talk um
so far
we don't really know canonical analyses
of pseudo calibration so it provides you
this construction of this linear
operator but it doesn't tell you how to
prove that that linear operator
satisfies all the properties you need it
to satisfy and thus far we basically
only know case-by-case proofs of this
for particular refutation problems
and these case-by-case proofs by the way
they are like very intense
you know there's like serious um random
matrix theory going on random matrices
uh with
highly dependent entries with very crazy
spectra there's a bunch of very
non-trivial uh random graph stuff going
on like pravesh has this paper on csps
where they do a very detailed analysis
of small subgraphs in uh in sparse
random graphs
so
this is
major technical lifting to prove these
prove these results
even though we think that pseudo
calibration should be universal it
should sort of always work without
worrying about details of the setting
that you're in this is one of the major
mysteries remaining in sos lower bounds
is why this universal technique works
even though to prove it we are always
appealing to very specific technical
facts
so well that was what i just said
there's a bunch of open problems to
figure out why pseudo calibration works
so
this is kind of i think
from 10 000 feet where we stand
um
we know a lot at this point of uh
lower bounds for average case refutation
problems
and we often have matching algorithms
okay
i don't want to say there's not work to
be done there is actually there's a lot
of there there are still a lot of
refrigeration problems that we don't
know how to handle we don't we're not
very good at sparse graphs for example
um
but you know at this point the list is
getting pretty long of of refutation
problems that we do understand sos lower
bonds for and pretty tight ones
we have this canonical technique for
proving these reputation lower bounds
but we still struggle to implement it
what do we hope is next
yeah no not sorry please yeah so you
mentioned that you'd say something about
uh the detection versus reputation
problem yeah did you already say the
thing you wanted to say yeah okay
but i'm not gonna say that much more and
actually if we have five minutes at the
end i'd love to discuss it because i
think it's
a conceptual issue
okay i'm just going to list a few things
that i think we don't understand well
enough and maybe some
wave at some ways we might try to
understand them better
so
refutation versus distinguishing
problems this is a really subtle issue
we said earlier
that the canonical way to think about
sos algorithms and lower bounds is as
refutation algorithms but we often want
to use the lower bounds as evidence for
hardness of a distinguishing problem
especially if you take this kind of
broad view this sos optimal view that an
sos lower bound is really evidence that
no polynomial time algorithm solves your
problem and i'm going to point out a
couple of real risks in that in that
view even though i think that ultimately
it's a good one but we have to be
careful how we implement it
so
you can't touch this and scroll it up
so just to illustrate this again with
planted clique you know
nobody said you had to use this system
of equations to distinguish
right you could augment
sos you could take any other polynomial
let's say it's a polynomial in in the
edges of the graph and also these
supposed gleek indicator variables
any other polynomial which with high
probability over a planted instance will
be non-negative if i evaluated at the
planted graph and the indicator for the
clique
so that means that if i give you a
planted graph like one with a cake like
these equations will be satisfiable
and then my algorithm could be take this
new augmented system of equations and
feed it to the sos algorithm and ask for
a refutation
right now if i get one then say well we
weren't in the planted case so it must
have been a gn half graph
so
on some level you would think that the
lower bound that we have for planted
clique like
it doesn't say anything about algorithms
like this so why do i believe that sos
doesn't work for this distinguishing
problem and even how could i get how
could i come to grips with this whole
space of algorithms that isn't really
well specified because somebody has to
choose this polynomial
this is a real problem and and actually
you know you can you can fool yourself
if you commit too hard to a refutation
problem that you associate to a
distinguishing problem so one place this
happens it didn't make it on the slide
is um in the stochastic block model
uh for people who haven't heard of it i
can tell you offline but for stochastic
block model there actually seems to be a
real gap between
the problem of distinguishing
sparse random graphs from sparse graphs
with planted communities and the problem
of refuting the existence in a sparse
random graph of a certain sparse k-way
cut so the natural refutation problem
that you associate to that
distinguishing problem it really just
has a different computational complexity
and if you associated the
refutation problem that you want to
associate
you would prove hardness results that
are too good that that suggests they
rule out algorithms that we know exist
so this is bad right we have to really
be careful what kind of
uh refutation problems we try to solve
when we solve a distinguishing problem
okay i want to give one more example of
some of some work
um that actually addressed this and and
just to point out that you really had to
work hard for this so this was by um
profession sleel and ryan o'donnell
where they said
something like the following well for
random csps there's a similar story
right i could try to there's refuting
and there's distinguishing and if i care
about the distinguishing problem
you know i'm trying to distinguish a
bunch of random clauses from random
clauses of the planted assignment and if
the planted assignment is drawn
uniformly at random from the hypercube
then it will be you know a balanced
vector or an almost balanced vector so
the sum of its entries will be you know
maybe zero or maybe like plus minus
square root of n depending on exactly
your your model and you could say well
for distinguishing i could just augment
my sos
uh the system i'm going to feed to sos
with this additional constraint and ask
can sos use this to do refutation
because then i would get an algorithm
for distinguishing random from planted
csbs
it turns out you can't but it's not a
trivial matter actually to to prove a
new theorem a new lower bond when you
augment sos with this additional
constraint
so how could we hope to resolve this
issue
well
i think
part of the magic of pseudo-calibration
is that it relates reputation and
distinguishing
in particular
if you're proving your refutation lower
bounds using the pseudo-calibration
technique you should never fool yourself
in this way
because you'll never prove a lower bound
that is that is stronger than the sort
of distinguishing hardness of the
distinguishing problem that you use to
prove your lower bound
not sure if that quite made sense but i
can i can try to expand on it
uh offline
basically when you do pseudo calibration
every polynomial that you could have
used to augment your system
will already be ruled out for free by
the linear operator that pseudo
calibration constructs
so if you if you can use pseudo
calibration to prove your lower bound
you're not going to fool yourself
but pseudo-calibration is really hard
and it also only seems to make sense for
pretty simple problems you know problems
where we are looking at
random graphs with product structure on
the edges or matrices with independent
entries things like this
please please please please
so
i think so in both the examples both
planet click and this uh paper with
snail and ryan yeah
we were working with sort of calibrated
uh pseudo distribution
i think one of the major issues with
sort of calibration even when you
succeed in doing it is that it does not
help you satisfy hard constraints
exactly
so it's it's like you know every
polynomial would have about the same
expectation as you expect
but if you add a constraint that this
polynomial should be zero into your
program
the pseudo calculated construction does
not immediately tell you uh you know
if you if you guys had worked if you
guys didn't work for the planting
distribution
where the planted
the planted thing was
uh
exactly balanced then pseudo celebration
should have for free satisfy this right
not really because you have truncated
the sort of calculator
but you use very tiny error when you do
that right well
part of the part of the work there is
really to understand how would that
affect and you know we managed to find a
way without really doing that
but that's also the critical problem i
think that contributes about 20 of the
pages in many of the
yes so okay yeah
just to translate this to higher level
um
i think i think we can emphasize the the
should we should not in quotes here like
you shouldn't have this problem but but
implementing that technically remains
challenging we don't we don't quite know
how to do it
[Music]
so there is no yes that's right so a
reputation algorithm is is stronger than
a distinguishing algorithm
because it'll distinguish random
instances from any graph of the cake
plate
right so i mean
so i don't exactly understand what this
little collaboration does but doesn't in
some sense have a choice about which
distribution yes
yes
there is a choice that's right and it's
not necessarily the kind of
[Music]
well if you choose an actual uniform
distribution what should happen is that
you'll prove reputation lower bounds
that uh reflect nicely the complexity of
the distinguishing problem you chose
distinguishing the natural number
[Music]
or bones you do not choose the uniform
distribution over the csp
yeah so the literal pattern distribution
are not really uniform you have to plant
a correct pair from distribution et
cetera
let me let me point out another another
subtlety which is what if i wanted to
when i really wanted to study reputation
with this pseudo-calibration technique
um
if if you have a problem where
reputation is harder than the natural
distinguishing problem you would
associate
you might need to construct a different
distinguishing problem one that was hard
to really reflect reflects that of
reputation this is this goes back to the
stochastic block model where alex and
collaborators have a paper where they
construct a
distribution on graphs that have planted
k-way cuts that distribution is not the
normal stochastic block model and it
should be harder to distinguish from
random graphs than just the statistic
block model its hardness of
distinguishing should reflect the
hardness of refuting k-way cuts in
uh sparse random graphs
so yeah there's this there's this pretty
subtle interplay between distinguishing
and reputation on the one hand choice of
planted problems on the other and
carrying these like like technically
implementing things when you really want
to prove lower bounds remains pretty
challenging okay i'm close out of time
and i wanted to hit one more one more
topic
which is about noise
so
if all you want to do if remember this
narrow view versus broadview from
earlier about how to interpret sos floor
mounts if you just want to know when
will sos algorithms work or not you know
because you wanted to know whether to
use sos or something else then you know
you don't need to worry about what i'm
about to say
but if you want to take sos lower bounds
as evidence of hardness for all
polynomial time algorithms for some
class of problems you've got to be a
little bit careful about what kind of
problems you you put into the bucket
in particular
there are some of the squares lower
bounds for problems that are just
computationally easy
the classic example of this is linear
equations that can be solved by gaussian
elimination right i give you a bunch of
linear equations this is in three
variables but whatever just a bunch of
linear equations over f2
linear degree sum of squares
corresponding to exponential running
times still can't refute random
instances of this
but of course gaussian elimination can
just solve them it's very easy
there's actually another example that
didn't make it onto my slides some
recent work um by a bunch of folks
here at ccsi
um
of using not gaussian elimination but
the ll
lattice algorithm to
do similar things not for not for linear
equations but for
actually a bunch of problems from
statistics so
there's scary situations like this this
looks like a real threat to this
hypothesis this sos is optimal
hypothesis
um
why is this going on well sos it's kind
of inherently noise robust i didn't
really explain why this is but it's it's
based on convex programming convex sets
are very stable to little perturbations
so you know when you if you take some
computational problem uh and you noise
up all you know everything about it all
of the all of the bits that specify it a
little bit
sos should kind of do the same thing on
a noisy instance of that problem than on
a clean instance but what that means is
that if you have problems whose
computational complexity inherently
changes when you go from like a clean
instance to a noisy instance sos won't
capture that right it'll just think that
problem is always hard because it's hard
when when you apply noise and that's
what's happening in these linear
equations this situation and i think
that's what's happening in this ll
situation but i don't understand it well
enough yet
so that means that if you want to if you
want to use sos as a lens for hardness
writ large you need to talk only about
sort of robust or noisy problems
and this brings me to the
um
this is what i just said this brings me
to the last thing that i wanted to say
which is to just to capture you know
what do we hope for in this whole
program like i've talked about
pseudo-calibration distinguishing
reputation uh noisiness what would be a
statement a theorem statement that would
capture a lot of these ideas this is
something i've been really interested in
while i'm here at simon's and i think
this is you know this program would
really uh wrap things up for sos lower
bounds in a nice way
um and then i'll conclude the talk so
there's this low degree conjecture
that's been floating around that is
supposedly characterizing um
hardness of a wide range of distribution
distinguishing problems
so in particular the low degree
conjecture says something like the
following
if i have two distributions
on some
uh
some n choose k coordinate hypercube or
this could be the real numbers or
something whatever uh k is not the clay
from k is like two or three so i'm
talking about graphs or tensors or
something
and then this one is a product
distribution and this one satisfies some
symmetry properties
and you can't distinguish these two
distributions by looking at their low
degree moments
then conjecturally
if you add a little bit of noise to this
distribution the resulting
distinguishing problem should be hard
for all polynomial time algorithms
so as prasad said earlier in the
semester um the most amazing thing about
this conjecture is that it still stands
after like three years you know it's
just like ridiculously
uh strong it's you know 10 times
stronger than p not equal np so it
should be broken by now and it's not
which is crazy i mean instances like we
had to refine the statements you know
you have to you have to be careful what
you mean by noisy and so on alex had
some some work on this but basically the
conjecture stands
and i think what would be amazing
evidence for it and also would tie a bow
on a lot of sos lower bounds would be to
prove an sos version of this conjecture
so an sos loaded reconjecture would just
replace all polynomial time algorithms
by constant degree sum of squares
algorithms and this you could hope to
prove unconditionally there's nothing
you know no complexity roadblock
standing in your way
okay so i'll wrap up with open problems
and then we'll be done
so as i said the sos loader reconjecture
would be very cool to resolve
uh there are lots of appealing special
cases of it and many of these are sort
of
you could view them as fleshing out the
list of
sos lower bounds in kong for concrete
distinguishing problems that we still
don't understand how to prove but you
know because they're implied by sos
loader reconjecture you have to be able
to resolve them before you can resolve
the whole conjecture one example is um
getting an sos lower bond that matches
the kesten's digum threshold for sparse
random graph problems
although there's i hear some recent
progress on this
another thing that i didn't mention at
all was all of these classical average
case problems i talked about they were
sort of
they were about distinguishing a very
random looking distribution from some
kind of structured distribution like gn
half versus g and half plus a k cleak
but often for
uh especially for crypto applications
but even in statistics if you want to
solve other kinds of distinguishing
problems you want to understand their
complexity like what if i have one
structured distribution versus another
structured distribution we just
conceptually i think lack the tools
right now to use this sos lens to
understand the complexity of those
problems
but but they're clearly going to be
important problems
um another thing that we conceptually
lack the tools to understand that ayush
pointed out
which is also important for crypto
applications is how to think about the
success probability of these
distinguishing algorithms um for crypto
you really want success probabilities
that are vanishingly tiny
uh whereas we often think about just
constant success probabilities
and then okay there are also lots of
technical problems one example is
understanding random matrices with
dependent entries like this shows up in
all of these sos lower bonds you have to
understand the structure of such
matrices how their spectrum behaves and
we're just in in very early days of
understanding how these matrices look
and if you want to make technical
progress you basically have to
understand this
okay thank you all for your attention um
happy to discuss more
[Applause]
but
thanks
so since we're five minutes over maybe
we'll go to break and um
i'll be around
you